Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
Netflix just dropped the arcane season 2 trailer
There's a whole bunch Easter Eggs here
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
It definitely seems like they have big plans for this
just because it was so successful.
Season one landed so hard, so.
Hopefully the show makes it for at least five
or six seasons Netflix not exactly known
for greenlighting a lot of shows beyond season three,
But when shows are really popular
like this, like Stranger Things,
they are known to go a little bit longer.
their reveal in the trailer.
They're releasing season two in November this year,
a little bit sooner than I would have expected.
It actually took them four years to make season one
and it also went up being one of the most expensive
animated series ever made, like League of Legends,
because they make so much money on that game
footed a lot of the build themselves.
But because they were doing that,
they had total control over how it was made
and how long they spent on.
So they just spent the time
it took to make it look amazing.
that's also why they released it in the weird way
they did during season one with a couple episodes
every single week instead of binge
dropping it all at the same time
because they essentially made it themselves,
then brought it to Netflix and we're like,
we wanted to release it this way is when Netflix
is like, okay, we're not spending money on it.
You can do whatever you want to with it.
my assumption is they'll probably do something similar
for season two episodes where they released
a couple episodes every single week
instead of releasing them all at the same time.
But this first trailer focuses
mostly on the cinched character.
He's in the middle of a blood transfusion in his lab
that we saw during season one.
He checks his pocket watch. It's ticking.
Then he looks up as you hear this deep breathing
sound in the camera.
This is a massive creature
that he's been experimenting on.
and it seemingly confirms a long running fan theory
that they're actually turning
the Zander character from season one into the warrior
character from the League of Legends.
Lore.
the Netflix arcane account
tweeted out a nightmarish augmentation
In the original League of Legends
Lore Warwick is a werewolf monster that's primarily
known for hunting the great allies of his
on the under city transformed by agonizing experiments.
His body is fuzed with an intricate system of chambers
and pumps like we see in the trailer here.
machinery filling his veins with an alchemical rage
bursting out of the shadows.
He prays upon those criminals
who terrorize the cities depths in the under city.
Here, Warwick is drawn to blood
and driven mad by its scent.
None whose spirit can escape him.
during the events of season
one, Vander was infused with shimmer.
Silk confronts him during their last encounter
before they strap him
to a chair in preparation for an experiment for singed.
So he was already going to be experimenting on him.
by and Jinx and everyone else arrived to save him.
Moments away from escaping, though there are multiple
explosions caused by powder rocking the canopy,
invader fights back against Zuko's remaining men
in his shimmer beads before getting stabbed by silk.
So desperate to protect vibe, Bender uses
the last of his strength to take shimmer, then
turning himself into a monstrous beast Vander,
then grabs
by and jumped out of the collapsing building.
But we jumped to episode nine at the end of the series.
Singed found Banda's body and took it back to his lab,
presumably
to see if there were possible
to bring someone back to life with his chemicals.
this also supports another fan theory
about singed back story in his dead daughter.
would you ever remember in the present day of the show,
he's had Vander theoretically
under experiments for the last seven years,
and he's turning him to this undead werewolf like beast
Cold War Wake, based on the League of Legends,
the version of the character,
presumably he'll turn him loose on the under city
and he'll wind up
fighting VI and the other characters
before they find out what's really happened to Vander.
Like, my God, it's actually you.
sort of like a Frankenstein's monster
kind of situation where the monster starts to realize
what's really going on.
Vander starts
to remember what actually happened to him.
but here's where we get to that fan theory
about Synge trying to conquer death,
trying to bring things back from the dead.
during the trailer,
you hear his pocket watch ticking and he checks it.
But you don't actually see inside it.
It might hold a picture of his daughter
who died before the events of season one.
they don't really get into his daughter
that much during season one,
but they imply that she died at some point.
It might have had something to do with his experiments.
Maybe he experimented on her.
Or maybe her death drove him to become what he is
today.
Drove him to start his experiments.
But I think they're trying to imply that he might be
trying to bring his daughter back from death.
Like that's the whole reason
why he's performing all these experiments.
so a lot of people are now theorizing
that his daughter might become
Oriana, the Lady of Clockwork
from the League of Legends Lore.
the only thing they've written
about that character in the law is that she was once
a curious girl of flesh and blood.
She's now a technological marvel
comprised entirely of clockwork.
She became gravely ill after an accident
in the lower districts of the city.
In her failing body had to be replaced
with an exquisite artifice, piece
by piece, accompanied by an extraordinary brass sphere
she built for companionship and protection.
Oriana is now free to explore
the wonders of Pilates over and beyond.
see, you can kind of see how her back story
dovetails a little bit with Singe daughters back story,
kind of the same way they're combining the van
der character from the show in the war
with character from the League of Legends lore
to make a slightly different version of the character.
the other major teasers at the end of season one were
jinx missile firing on the pillow over counsel,
implying that the war between built over in the under
city will start at the beginning of the season.
It will comprise a big portion of season two,
if not spilling into season three and beyond.
in probably the other biggest teaser from
the end of season one is Victor's slow transformation
into the Machine Herald from the League of Legends Lore
So at the end of Season one, he had used
the shimmer given to him by singed,
going back to the singed character to enhance his body
with his use of the
hex core, seemingly starting his transformation
into his appearance during the game,
which is more of a cybernetic blend of techno, organic,
magically infused components and body parts
like, a fusion of man magic in technology.
so them leaning on singed transformations
and experiments in the trailer might be them hinting
that he's also responsible for helping transform Victor
even faster into the machine.
Harold
I wouldn't be surprised if he's nearly fully cybernetic
by the end of season two, given the rate
of his transformations during season one.
But they might try to push that out to season three.
There've been a couple.
Arcane season two promos
that people have found in, in the background.
It seems like if you zoom in enhanced enough,
you can actually see a machine.
Harold looking kind of Victor
like his limbs are completely different.
Looking.
so really does seem like he transforms a lot during
the events of season two,
even if he doesn't fully transform.
it even though it seems that they're positioning Cisco
as an overarching antagonist
for the events of the entire series,
I think they want you to fall 5050 on each side.
Like, do you support the under city?
Do you support. Pillow over.
Because the whole idea is that
there are terrible people on both sides of the conflict
That was kind of what they were using Jason's storyline
for inside the council.
Like as he became part of the council,
he found out how corrupt it actually was.
it even though Cisco is doing all these terrible things
they wanted to make it seem during season
one like he did have some morality to him as opposed to
siege, who seemed like he had absolutely no limits.
So let me know in the comments.
Who do you think is going to be the actual main villain
in the next couple of seasons?
Andrew.
Game of Thrones fashion is very
much like things are inside the world of Westeros.
you got a lot of alliances forming within both sides
of the conflict in across both sides of the conflict,
and a lot of backstabbing
going on on both sides of this
kind of like
we saw by working with Jace by the end of season one.
Like that idea will continue into season two.
part of the irony of the end of season one
is that Jay-Z met with Sisqo and made terms for peace,
giving the under city total autonomy
like complete freedom in while
that final scene with the council was going down
they had actually approved the peace treaty.
So it was actually going to go down until Jinx
that, the missile off blowing up the council chamber.
Susan, I tried to totally throw
the character under the bus.
They want to make it seem like a parallel to Jinx when
she was younger, causing a similar type of accident.
This sort of sets off the next big stage of the story,
like the next big plot
like there's a giant conflict between under city
in built over it's probably jinx his fault
but everyone posts all your theories
for season two in the comments
and we'll probably get the next really big trailer
in the next couple of months.
Since the season isn't dropping till November,
they tend to wait a little bit longer
to release the really big trailers.
there's a bunch of big stuff coming up.
Big animated stuff too.
We have X-Men 97 episodes.
That'll be coming up pretty soon.
I'll be doing videos for all of those.
there's also that animated Spider-Man series.
They're calling it Friendly Neighborhood Spider-Man.
Now, it used to be called Spider-Man freshman year.
That's coming at the end of the year.
you We have Invincible Season two, Part two.
But they didn't say exactly
when that's going to premiere.
I'm assuming it's
going to be sometime in the first half of the year,
but hopefully we'll get a trailer for that pretty soon.
even though I think the animation on Arcane is way
better,
Invincible is also probably
one of the best animated series out there right
now, not just best superhero series,
but just best animated series in general.
make sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss anything.
Everyone click here for that
brand new Henry Cavill Warhammer Trailer video
and click here for all my Invincible Season 2 videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Happy New Year and I'll see you guys in the next one!